I would heard it on the street
a man's tragedy occurred I didn't know
how to react I had to know the latest
word if it had been a hijacked airplane
my resolve it would be steeled another
Ryder truck explosion and I pray all
would be healed or an extremist with a
knife I would go out and donate blood
but I knew just what I should do and I
saw that they'd used a gun I got on
Facebook status updates started typing
like the breeze cuz it's the perfect
chance to advance my political beliefs
it's in the face of acts of terror I
won't be dyed-in-the-wool unless the
weapon had a tiny little metal thing you
pull cuz there's no time to come
together express sorrow for the sad when
people have a right to on something I
don't want them to have with a crime
scene still roped off we could unify
sorrow or ask was it with a gun
in a place not called Chicago you could
plug all your beliefs until your face is
turning red or you could also just
respond the way you would have if
instead it was of laying a bomb a ride a
truck a vest or with a knife if they
were drowned or hung or thrown from
buildings very burned alive if they were
kidnapped by the hundreds oldest slavery
with vigor I'd respond with unity but if
the weapon had a trigger I've heard it
on the street a mass tragedy did ensued
when I saw it was an immigrant I knew
what I should do I got on Facebook
status updates started typing like the
breeze because it's the perfect chance
to advance my political